[Applause]
I grew up on a beef farm in Missouri and
like everybody else that raises
livestock, we raise a lot of our own
feed to stay in business and we raise
corn and soybeans and hay and we grind
this stuff up into a flour and we'd add
vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals. make pellets. You feed those
calves for about six, nine months and
then you ship them off to be butchered
or maybe to other feeders and you always
save back the very best ones for
yourself and you knock them in the head
and eat them. It's a real simple cycle
on the farm. And the thing that
fascinated me as a teenager was that we
went to a great deal of trouble for
those calves. And yet as a family, we
ate out of the very same fields. We'd
keep back five rows of corn for oursel.
We had a garden at the end of the field
where we grew our peas and beans and
squash and tomatoes. And we wanted to
live to be a hundred with no aches and
pains and we didn't give ourselves the
very same vitamins and minerals and
trace minerals that we gave the calves.
And I always used to ask my dad, I'd
say, "Hey pops, how come we go to all
that trouble for those calves and and
not for oursel?" And he'd say, "Shut up,
boy. Getting farm fresh food, fresh air,
lots of free exercise. Don't ask
complicated questions." And I was glad
to get rid of the farm exercise and go
to a school at the University of
Missouri. And there my major was in
animal husbandry and nutrition. My minor
was in field crops and soils. And I
began to learn technical things about
soil chemistry and how it related to
tons and bushels per acre and a
economics. But I didn't get an answer to
my basic question until I became a
freshman veterary student at the
University of Missouri. And there I
learned that the reason why we put all
these vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals into animal feeds, bottom line,
is because we don't have insurance for
them. We don't have Blue Cross, Blue
Shield, major medical hospitalization,
Medicare, Medicaid. And if we were to
use a human health care type of system
for animals, it'd be sticker shock for
you. and your hamburger would cost you
$275 a pound. Boneless, skinless chicken
breast would be $450 bucks a pound.
Dozen eggs would be $50 just to pay for
the health care. So, we learned that we
could keep the price of animal products
such as meat and dairy and poultry and
eggs down to where the average American
could afford them simply by
significantly reducing or totally
eliminating health care costs. And we do
that in animals by preventing and curing
diseases with nutrition. Well, after
graduating vet school, I went to Africa
for a couple of years and got to work
with Marlon Perkins from the old Mutual
of Omaha WoW Kingdom days. That was kind
of a kick. Got to play Frank Buck, use a
tranquilizer gun, trump all over Central
and South Africa for a couple of years.
And then Marlon sent me a telegram and
invited me back to the States. Uh he'd
gotten a 7.5 million grant from the
National Institutes of Health. And this
was more than 30 years ago. And this was
to study pollution and ecology and the
environment. And my job as the wildlife
veterinarian on the project was to do
autopsies of animals that died of
natural causes in the big zoos around
the United States. And I was supposed to
identify or find a species of animals
that was ultra sensitive to pollution.
And we're going to use that animal much
like the old coal miners used to use
canaries. You know how that goes. They
take the canary down in the mine and if
methane gas or carbon monoxide were to
leak in the mine, the canaries were more
sensitive than the men and would drop
off the Persian die and long before the
men were in danger of suffocating or
blowing up. Well, to make a long story
short, after some 12 plus years of
working on this project, I had done some
17,500 autopsies and over 454 species of
animals plus 3,000 human beings for a
comparison. And what I learned was that
every animal and human being who dies of
natural causes dies of a nutritional
deficiency disease. And I got kind of
excited about nutrition again. And I
wrote 75 scientific papers on the
subject. Uh wrote chapters for eight
multi-author textbooks. Actually
contributed a textbook myself, a
thousand pages, 2,000 illustrations. and
uh through the news releases that were
in the big universities I worked with. I
was on 2020 was in 1,700 newspapers
around the world through the UPI and AP
newswire services and with all this
public exposure and with all this
scientific exposure I couldn't get
people who are in a position of
authority either in medical research or
in politics to get too concerned or
interested in preventing and curing
diseases in human beings with nutrition
just like we did in animals. Well, I got
frustrated enough. I went back to school
in Portland, Oregon, became a physician,
and I practiced there for 12 years as a
general family practitioner, and uh I
sewed up chainsaw wounds, delivered
babies, um used everything that I'd
learned in veterary nutrition on my
human patients. And it was no surprise
to me that it worked just as well in
people as it did in animals. Well, to
get started, I always like to talk about
longevity. And the human being has the
genetic potential to live healthily, to
be 120. And I'm going to prove that to
you in just a minute. Unfortunately,
Americans do a lousy job when it comes
to longevity. Our average lifespan in
the United States is 75.5, about half
what we're genetically capable of. In
1990, when the World Health Organization
examined the top 32 industrialized
nations on Earth, the United States came
out 17th. There was actually 16 other
countries whose peoples live longer than
we do. We ranked 19th in healthfulness.
That meant that there were 18 other
countries whose peoples live longer than
we do before they develop heart disease
and cancer and diabetes and arthritis
and osteoporosis. We ranked 23rd when it
came to live births and first year
survivability as a babies. And we ranked
dead last 32 out of 32 when it came to
preventing birth defects. Now what all
this means is we have the highest priced
health care system in the world but not
the best. It also means that we have the
most envied health care system in the
world but not the best. We have the most
technologically advanced health care
system in the world, but not the best. I
had a good friend by the name of
Christopher Bird for many, many years,
over 20 years. And Chris was a
best-selling author on books on
organically grown food. He was an expert
in this subject. And I was always trying
to give him vitamins and minerals, and
he refused to take them. And he tell me,
"Doc, I bring my own cooler. I don't eat
any uh hotel food. I bring my own
organically grown food, and so I don't
need to take vitamins and minerals."
Well, I was changing planes again in
Atlanta. Had an hour to kill. picked up
the local newspaper and guess whose
obituary I found in the newspaper? Chris
Bird. Of course, again, he was a
best-selling author of books, The Secret
Life of Plants, The Secrets of the Soil,
and he died at age 68 from a ruptured
aneurysm, a type of stroke, seven and a
half years before the average American
dies. And he led a pristine life, lived
up in the mountains, had an organically
grown garden, collected herbs, you know,
like Ule Gibbons and ate wild hickory
nuts and all those kind of things. And
because of his belief, he died of a
copper deficiency. And I'll show you in
a minute that copper deficiency causes
ruptured aneurysms. It's just a tragic
thing that that people have so much to
give and die at less than half their
genetic potential for longevity. A lot
of people say to me, "Doc, I don't need
to take vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals because I use herbs." Now,
herbs are not nutrition. You have to
understand that herbs are not nutrition.
They are great plant medicines. Uh
they're safer, they're more economical,
in most cases are more effective than
prescription medications that doctors
will give you. But they're plant
medicines. If you have diarrhea, they
can tighten you up. If you have
constipation, they can loosen you up. If
you have hypertension or high blood
pressure, they can bring it down. If you
have a fever, then bring it down. But
don't expect to get enough calcium or
selenium or boron or copper or vitamin A
from herbs. Well, I've been doing
biomedical research and clinical
research in animals and human beings.
And I can tell you no matter how you
look at health and longevity, whether it
be in animals or human beings, there's
only really two concepts you have to
deal with. Concept number one I refer to
as avoid stepping on the landmines. This
is where you don't want to throw away
your healthy physical body wastefully.
You don't want to smoke. Don't abuse
alcohol. Don't do drugs. Don't jog down
the highway at 2 o'clock in the morning
wearing an all black ninja suit. You're
going to get hit by a truck mirror.
Right? Whenever a doctor says, "Here's
our options." Never say, "Doc, whatever
you say, you're the you're the doctor."
When a doctor says, "Here's our
options." What you want to do is say,
"Look, I want copies of all these
records and test. I want copies of the
X-rays." And go visit three other
doctors and three other hospitals. You
want to talk to 12 of their living
patients that had gone through this
procedure. Talk to them. See if you
really want to do this. I mean, you do
this for your driveway and your roof and
your fence and your yard and all that
kind of stuff. Why not for your own
physical body? That's concept number
one. Now that you've avoided the
landmines, you're in a good position to
do all the positive things that you need
to do to go on to live to be over 100.
Basically, what you want to do is take
all the essential nutrients. 60, that's
6 O minerals, 16 vitamins, 12 essential
amino acids, and three essential fatty
acids. They're called essential
nutrients for two reasons. Number one,
your body cannot manufacture them. You
must consume these every day, either as
food or as supplements. Number two, if
any one of these essential nutrients is
missing for a couple of months, couple
of years, you get on the average 10
deficiency diseases. You have everything
to gain, nothing to lose by
supplementing properly. Well, the
medical profession, of course, has this
malignant dumb belief that you can get
everything you need from your four food
groups. My favorite article of all time
in the press was April 6th, 1992, Time
magazine cover article, The Real Power
of Vitamins. New research shows it may
help fight cancer, heart disease, and
the ravages of aging. Six positive
pages. If you haven't read it, I'd urge
you to go to a public library, school
library, dig it out, and read it. There
was only one negative sentence and as
you might guess it was offered by a
medical doctor who was actually
contacted by the writer of the article
said, "What do you think about vitamins
and minerals and and trace minerals as
supplements for human nutrition?" Here's
what he said. Quote, "Popping vitamins
doesn't do you any good?" sniffs Dr.
Victor Herbert, a professor of medicine
at New York City's Mount Sinai Medical
School. We get all the vitamins we need
in our diets and taking supplements just
gives you expensive urine. Unquote. Now,
Missouri translation of that is you're
just peeing away your money. You might
as well wad up your dollars, throw them
in a toilet, and flush them away. You
can get everything you need from your
four food groups is what he's trying to
say. Well, I'd rather pee out 50 cents
or a dollar a day worth of excess
vitamins and minerals. That's cheap
insurance. Think about it. How much
money you spend for coffee or soft
drinks or newspapers and that kind of
stuff every day. 50 cents to a dollar a
day to maintain and repair your body.
And it's kind of fascinating that most
people don't do it. Just remember when
you pay that doctor out of your own
pocket or indirectly through insurance
or indirectly through taxes and
Medicare, Medicaid, not a single penny
of that goes to better understand,
manage, treat, prevent or cure
catastrophic diseases in kids, breast
cancer and women, prostate cancer and
men. And a lot of people ask me, why did
you call your original tape deads don't
lie? Well, that's because I I believed
for a long time because I'd done medical
research for over 20 years in large
medical research institutes, medical
schools, the various laboratories. And I
always had a belief in the medical
system. But I I was very disappointed
when I learned that doctors don't know
the most about health and longevity.
Doctors don't know the most about
disease. They do know about procedures.
You know, how to fix your bones when you
break them and that sort of thing, how
to do a CAT scan. And so, I began to
look in the medical journals. And sure
enough, the first article ever published
on health and longevity of American
doctors was published in JAMAMA in June
15th, 1895, a little over 100 years ago.
They said at that time doctors lived to
be 54.6.
I redid the study 97 years later using
the same obituary techniques that they
did in JAMAMA. This was um January 20th,
1993, that particular issue of JAMAMA.
And it turned out the doctors lived to
be 57.6. I rounded up to 58 to give them
the benefit of the doubt. And doctors
just went berserk when I said that. I
mean, this was the most outrageous thing
that they ever heard. My principle is my
my premise is that doctors don't live as
long as the average couch potato in
America. And I purposely put that figure
out there at 58 to try and challenge
people. Well, doctors immediately looked
at all the insurance actuarial charts.
They got 250,000 dead doctors. They
said, "Your group's too small." So, they
looked at 250,000 dead doctors. They
say, "Doctors don't live to be 58. They
die at 62. They still don't live to be
75.5 like the average couch potato. We
actually reran this again using the
entire obituary history for 1996. And
for the entire 1996 of all the doctors
dying in 1996 with all the medical
treatments and drugs and and procedures
and everything and transplants, doctors
in that study lived to be 70. Still five
and a half years short of the average
couch potato in America. So they still
have never proven that doctors live as
long as everybody else. And that's why
dead doctors don't lie.